ce festival c'est donc là c'est la
deuxième édition l'idée c'est d'inviter
les traducteurs à parler des livres
qu'ils ont traduit et c'est toujours
passionnant parce que même quand il ya
un grand lecteur on lit beaucoup mais la
contrepartie c'est qu'on lui fixe un
traducteur lui va passer six mois un an
sur le livre a travaillé sur ce livre
est donc c'est toujours passionnante
dont on ne parlait de ce livre va se
poser des questions que nous on se pose
pas
aller au coeur du texte se demander
comment le livre est construit pourquoi
tel personnage s'appelle comme ça il va
chercher des références et tout ça il va
essayer le mettre dans sa traduction
donc c'est un des meilleurs connaisseurs
de du livre de l'auteur de cette
littérature
l'idée c'est vraiment de parler des
livres et c'est pour ça qu'on en fait un
rendez vous
annuel c'est parce que d'élire des
chefs-d'oeuvre des livres entre qu'il
est nécessaire important intéressant de
parler il y en a tous les ans qui
sortent et les les auteurs à découvrir
par tous c'est le sujet c'était la
traduction on aurait pu pour le grand
public voilà épuisé le sujet assez vite
et s'est lancé dans des querelles de
spécialistes là vraiment l'idée c'est de
parler des livres c'est les traducteurs
qui vous donne envie parce qu'ils
connaissent bien hauteur parce qu'ils
connaissent bien un roman qui vous donne
envie d'ouvrir le livre
c'est un festival ouvert à tout le monde
c'est le grand public qu'on veut
tous les types de lecteurs c'est pour ça
qu'on parle des romans des romans du
monde entier de l'arabe du catalan
européen des romans du maghreb de la
mairie des gens qui lisent de la poésie
qui lisent des policiers de la
littérature jeunesse la littérature de
l'imaginaire
m
c'est un cadre enchanteur donc est
historique parce que c'est la demeure du
duc et la duchesse de windsor et donc a
déjà ce
ce passé
franco anglais bras qui est intéressant